fibre optique santé éducation ou encore
patrimoine l'engagement du département
pour les zones rurales se veut ambitieux
avec le déploiement de la fibre optique
avant trois ans un deuxième bus pmi ou
encore le soutien financier pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux des
engagements pour répondre aux angoisses
des habitants des zones rurales inquiet
notamment de la fusion envisagée avec le
département des hauts-de-seine et qui
consacre aussi le rôle majeur de la
ville de rambouillet rambouillet va
devenir la capitale de la ruralité
regroupe les deux territoires d'action
départemental dédié à la ruralité et on
les installe à rambouillet et nous
auront naturellement des antennes à
houdan et dans le boni roi qui sont très
éloignées de rambouillet et à côté de ça
nous aurons aussi l'agent ce que nous
avons créé pour la zone rurale lg neri
qui sera installée rambouillet et qui
verra sa dotation venant du seul conseil
départemental doublé le nouveau plan
présenté en présence notamment du
président du sénat s'inscrit en
complément des assises de la ruralité
engagé fin 2015
parmi les autres propositions exposées
le développement des services au public
dans les gares rural la question de la
mobilité est très important il ya peu de
transport collectif dans l'espace rural
comment on résout la question de la
mobilité on n'a pas évoqué ce soir c'est
un sujet difficile à traiter
extrêmement onéreux et c'est un sujet
indispensable le plan pour
l'amélioration du service au public sera
votée avant la fin de l'année au total
d'ici 2021 le département des yvelines
promet d'engager 100 millions d'euros
pour la ruralité